un château à toronto comme tu peux voir
nous sommes j'ai pierre lassonde la clé
un fil et puis ici bas c'est encore pire
parce que ce mur là il était plein plein
plein de tableau à partir du plancher
jusqu'au plafond
pierre lassonde et étrangement de bonne
humeur pour un homme qui s'est fait
voler 96 tableaux ont tous deux valises
et des toiles de grande valeur notamment
des supports côté paul émile borduas
jean paul lemieux plusieurs rappels ici
avec un ris opel 47 et pvi me l'ont volé
ou fille
mais qui sont les voleurs monsieur la
sambre il nous dit qu'il a été volé j'ai
bien passé nous les voleurs
passions privées le musée national des
beaux-arts du québec exposé jusqu'en mai
quatre-vingt seize tableaux qui
appartient à pierre lassonde
le musée a organisé l'exposition salon
salle à manger un peu comme si on était
chez pierre lassonde c'était d
impressionner seulement des
impressionnistes canadien par exemple
vous vous rappelez ce grand mur vide à
toronto
le revoici reproduit à québec avec la
majorité ses tableaux grand
collectionneur d'art québécois pierre
lassonde possède 400 toiles il a un très
bon oeil très banal ce connaisseur
c'est un connaisseur et j'oserais qu'il
connaît avec la tête et le coeur etc les
meilleurs des connaisseurs ça c'est
votre bureau c'est un fait ça c'est mon
havre de paix c'est mon bureau alors ici
c'est de le calme le plus absolu alors
ça cette paix là ici main un bureau avec
une collection de souvenirs
une photo de sa rencontre avec fidel
castro des exemplaires du livre à succès
qu'il a écrit non pas sur l'art mais sur
l'or alors ça c'est elle d'éditions
originales et puis ça c était la
dernière édition ici d'en garder si ça
car si c'est beau car c'est bien dans
l'or qu'il a fait fortune
ça c'est de l'or ben oui ce qui est
jaune c'est de lancer des onze d'or 1985
avec un partenaire ils achètent pour 2
millions des droits dans un projet de
mine d'or au nevada bingo en fait ça
c'est un truc incroyable parce que on a
parti avec deux millions d'armes
et puis on a vendu la compagnie 18 à 18
ans plus tard pour 3.2 milliards alors
c'est sûr on a fait du 36% composées par
elle
pendant 18 ans
son modèle d'affaires est simple et il
l'a plusieurs fois utilisée ils achètent
des droits dans un projet minier
et si le promoteur trouve de l'or pierre
lassonde eux touchent des redevances
pendant toute la durée de l'exploitation
de la mine défaite vous avez rien à
faire alors lynch tout l'argent alors on
a des revenus cette année de 450 500
millions j'avais été un employé
ceci c'est le plus beau modèle de la
faim qui existe est incroyable
incroyablement riche pierre lassonde est
devenu un grand philanthrope 7 des
tableaux de l'exposition passions
privées resteront à québec
il les a données au musée
et ce nouveau pavillon que l'on
construit il va s'appeler comment
pavillon pierre lassonde
il donne 10 des 100 millions que coûte
le projet pierre lassonde a posé une
condition principale
il fallait que nous vous avions soit une
merveille architecturale et qu'on
organise un concours international pour
trouver la bonne firme d'architectes
c'est le consortium au mas de new york
qui a obtenu contrat le verre sera
omniprésent de grands espaces des
galeries en sous sol un auditorium un
café à l'entrée et un escalier que l'on
a voulu majestueux
c'est un escalier monumental qui nous
donne accès au premier étage mais
également un étage 0 qui lui ou vers un
passage qui nous va nous conduire
jusqu'aux merci aux pavillons existants
du musée actuel
ainsi donc pierre lassonde aiment le
goût regardez ce tout nouvel édifice à
l'université york de toronto à
l'intérieur l'école d'ingéniérie la
sonde dont de pierre lassonde 25
millions il y à aussi sur le même campus
un autre édifice qui porte son nom
autre denrée 125 millions à l'université
de l'utah où pierre lassonde a jadis
fait son mba n'ouvrira l'institut la
sonde d'entrepreneurship et les studios
la sonde y logement 400 étudiants
il ne faudrait quand même pas oublier
des 15 millions à l'université de
toronto et les 8 millions à
polytechnique montréal
son nom est partout et c'est voulu
ce que je me suis dit c'est que quand je
regarde la fine entre pied au québec
c'est déplorable littéralement c'est
déplorable
alors je me suis dit pierre la meilleure
chose que tu peux faire c'est d'être un
exemple m dont méritons non ok
simplement pour dire aux gens écouter
vous pouvez faire la même chose ou si
les riches au québec ne serait pas assez
généreux selon lui je regarde devant
jean coutu par les handis fait une chose
extraordinaire lui aussi alors il y en a
des québécois qui ont sortis de leur
coquille
mais il ya trop de québécois qui ont les
poches très profondes
mais les mains courtes les gens qui ont
de l'argent dans ses vrais sens en fait
monsieur à son ne voulait être
exemplaire avec le geste qu'il a posé au
musée en faisant un don majeur de cette
échelle là au fond ça dit à tous les
autres hommes d'affaires
voilà ce que vous pouvez faire pour
votre communauté voilà comment
s'impliquer tout en visitant sa maison
est grande comme un parlement des bombes
ronde sous son côté pierre lassonde nous
parle de ses autres projets il a
notamment accepté de devenir président
du conseil d'administration du conseil
des arts du canada
mais sa grande passion c'est sa
collection qu'il ne peut s'empêcher
d'enrichir un mot vis d'eux un mec
nicole vous ne l'achetez soldats ouais
ouais c'est quand même bien le passage
des voleurs ça libère de l'espace pour
de nouveaux tableaux
vous savez pas combien on dit la vache
des discours